now we haven't even had the election yet
here in the united states
but already concerns are going to its
aftermath and the potential
for anarchy on the streets however
don't panic facebook is on the case we
need to be doing everything that we can
to reduce the chances of violence
civil unrest in the wake of this
election the social media giant
is reported to already have a slew of
emergency measures that are being
planned
facebook has already promised to slow
the spread of viral
content to lower the standards of what's
considered an inflammatory post and get
suppressed
to tweak the news feeds of what users
see
and furthermore to suppress dangerous
posts in such circumstances
there's some content that needs to be
removed and there's some content that
needs to not have access to the facebook
tools that create virality
facebook does not have the best record
when it comes to this kind of thing
these are the same tools that were
deployed in myanmar
facebook was accused of inflaming hate
speech in the country
that was back when forces cracked down
on rohingya muslims and it got very
ugly
[Music]
foreign
the united nations has actually called
out facebook for
not stopping the widespread calls for
violence and the hate speech that
encouraged and emboldened those
who were ready to kill i'm afraid that
facebook has now turned into a beast and
not what it originally intended
it has substantively contributed to the
level of acrimony and dissension and
conflict if you will
within the public hate speech is
certainly of course a part of that
in 2018 facebook was once again called
out
for inflaming anti-muslim riots this
time
in sri lanka
[Music]
facebook has apologized for both
circumstances saying that they were
wrong in myanmar
and in sri lanka but now facebook's
approach to american politics is being
scrutinized
facebook decided to suppress the reports
about hunter biden and his
shady dealings in ukraine drawing anger
and
outrage from republicans i think they're
a threat to democracy when you can shut
down the flow of information
when when you can censor what millions
of americans would see
that's a threat to democracy facebook
says this was all
done in the name of fact checking so
with a controversial election and fears
of violence in the united states
will facebook repeat its pattern of
behavior and
fan the flames making things worse or
will its newly discovered art of
censorship
save lives and restore calm well they
are censorship and
they've been warming us up to this for a
very long time it's not only censorship
at this point
this is them letting us know that they
are going to decide how the conversation
goes
they are going to we should entrust our
power into them
uh because they're going to protect all
of us uh from
uh mean posts that they i guess believe
are gonna
uh stoke violence in the aftermath of
the election so it's it even it goes
beyond just
the censorship we're used to this is
them saying we are going to control
the conversation we are going to control
what happens in this country what you
see
what you hear and what gets out there um
it's next level
one of the things about these
organizations is they
look down on the american people we know
this they think the american people are
stupid and violent
and they think that they have to protect
us from ourselves they think that we
have they have to protect us from our
own speech of our neighbors
our friends our co-workers and the
public figures and news organizations
that we want to hear from so they're
nannying us they think that they're
doing some sort of ultimate good
and of course anyone who thinks that
they are capable of doing such good
that's classic like
the dictator mentality isn't it thinking
that you know what's best for everyone
else
and you will use every tool at your
disposal to make sure that your
idea of what's best and your and what's
appropriate
is uh the only thing that gets out and
and and shaping how people
think and speak